vamos a ver si podemos crear una
transformación lineal que sea una
rotación una rotación en un ángulo theta
y esta función lo que hace es tomar un
vector en r2 y arrojar no es una versión
transformada una versión rota da de ese
mismo vector otra forma de decirlo más
bien una forma de describirlo es que la
rotación en un ángulo theta de un vector
x simplemente va a ser eso una rotación
de no de teta grados theta grados ok del
vector x del vector x en sentido
antihorario en sentido antihorario y
cuando digo sentido antihorario estoy
pensando en el sentido contrario a las
manecillas del reloj ok entonces para ir
aclarando todas estas ideas vamos
haciéndolo en un dibujo
y ahí tenemos uno de mis ejes otro de
mis ejes digamos este es el eje x 1 este
es el eje x 2 y digamos que por aquí
tenemos el vector
y aquí está el vector x y que vamos a
rotarlo en un ángulo de 90 grados de 90
grados de teta grados
pero no quise decir 90 puede ser
cualquier ángulo theta ok entonces esta
es la rotación en un ángulo theta del
vector x ok entonces la afirmación que
tenemos es que esta transformación de
rotación es una transformación lineal en
cuyo caso nos gustaría después ver cuál
es la matriz asociada a esta
transformación entonces primero vamos a
demostrar que es lineal y para eso hay
que mostrar primero que la rotación de
una suma de dos ángulos es igual a la
suma de las rotaciones
aunque igual a esta suma la rotación de
x más la rotación de y ok esto lo vamos
a ver visualmente vamos a mostrar que es
lineal en unos dibujitos por ejemplo qué
pasaría si yo aquí tengo el vector de ok
y entonces si yo tengo aquí el vector y
vamos a construir un su vector rotado
por un ángulo theta
digamos es más o menos este
esta es la rotación de un ángulo theta
de iu ok
aquí está el ángulo teta y ahora hay que
ver quiénes x mas x más y es simplemente
poner este aquí más o menos es este
vector de aquí este es x + de verdad
aquí estamos colocando y encima déjenme
déjenme quitarlo no se ve tan claro más
o menos es así
este digamos sería x más éste es poner
yen en una posición no estándar verdad
no anclado sobre el origen sino sobre x
para que podamos ver quién es x más éste
es x más déjenme ponerlo con este color
x + ahora vamos a rotar este vector en
un ángulo teta ok vamos a poner eso con
vamos a ponerlo con verde
entonces si nosotros rotamos z
- se vería
algo así esta es la ruta aquí este es un
ángulo theta verdad entonces esta es la
rotación en un ángulo theta de x más
ahora bien qué pasa si rotamos aquí
tenemos ya la rotación de iu en un
ángulo theta y tenemos la rotación en un
ángulo theta de x entonces si ponemos
este vector encima de este otro más o
menos nos da digo aquí pueden ser
algunos errores de dibujo pero si se ve
más o menos que la suma de estas dos
rotaciones fue igual a la rotación de la
suma entonces hasta este momento ya
hemos visto que si cumple esta propiedad
de separar las sumas muy bien ahora
tenemos que demostrar que la rotación en
un ángulo theta de un escalamiento de un
vector es decir multiplicarlo por
cualquier constante es esa constante por
la rotación del vector original ok y
para eso vamos a hacer otro dibujo
vamos a pintar otros ejes
poner esto que así y esto así que este
es esos son los ejes y digamos que
tenemos nuestro vector x por aquí
este es nuestro vector x si nosotros
rotamos o más bien si nosotros
rescatamos primero con un 11 con una
multiplicación por una constante en
realidad estamos pensando en estirar
lobo en cogerlo según sea el caso por un
factor de escala ok esto sería c x qué
pasa si ahora rotamos cx en un ángulo
theta pues vamos a tener algo así verdad
más o menos
un ángulo teta aquí está el ángulo theta
y esta es la rotación en un ángulo theta
dcx pero fíjense que si nosotros rotamos
primero x esto simplemente se debe
conservar el mismo ángulo verdad
entonces y la misma distancia entonces
aquí va a estar nuestra rotación de x en
un ángulo theta y simplemente hay que
estirar tanto como habíamos estirado
aquí entonces en efecto si se cumple
esta propiedad que pinte en blanco de
que la rotación de un múltiplo de un
múltiplo de un vector es multiplicar por
esa misma constante la rotación del
vector x muy bien entonces si en efecto
tenemos que esta transformación la
rotación en un ángulo theta de x es
lineal si éste es lineal quiere decir
que podemos expresarla como la
multiplicación de una matriz que de
hecho vamos a llamarle a y que es de 2 x
2 porque va de reducen r 2 por cada
vector x que se encuentre en el espacio
r 2
y lo que tenemos que hacer como ya hemos
visto en otros vídeos es tomarnos la
matriz identidad en este caso de 2 x 2
que va a ser esta matriz la 1 0 0 1 y
aquí lo que nos está dando es son dos
vectores los dos vectores canónicos de
r2 verdad y 1 10/2 entonces tenemos que
ver dónde van a parar estos dos vectores
al aplicarle la rotación para definir
cómo es la matriz de transformación de
las rotaciones ok entonces estamos
diciendo que la rotación
la rotación está dada por esta matriz ah
ok que es simplemente aquella que tiene
como columnas a la rotación en un ángulo
theta de 1 esta es nuestra primera
nuestra primera columna que de hecho
vamos a describirlo bien el vector que
uno es el 10 que es esta rotación y como
segunda columna vamos a tener la
rotación en un ángulo theta pero del
vector 0 1
ok entonces esta matriz esta matriz de
aquí es la que queremos encontrar y para
eso vamos a hacer nuevamente un tercer
dibujo
nuestros ejes nuevamente
vamos a hacerlo por aquí
uno de los ejes
déjenos hacerlo más derechito
otro de los ejes
ahí está
entonces tenemos estos ejes y digamos
que más o menos esta altura tenemos el
vector
1 este es el vector
este es uno ya que hacia arriba vamos a
pintar con amarillo el vector 2
seguir más o menos la línea de los ejes
- más o menos hasta aquí está 2
de dos muy
ok entonces ahí están mis lectores
canónicos qué pasa si yo roto este
vector por un ángulo theta que entonces
si nosotros rotamos un ángulo theta
digamos más o menos como esta altura
ahí está la rotación esta es la rotación
la rotación en un ángulo theta del
vector e1 entonces este vector de aquí
es lo que nos va a dar la primera
columna verdad vamos a tratar de
encontrar sus coordenadas sus
coordenadas de este de este vector
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
definitivamente empezar a construir un
triángulo rectángulo es decir este
triángulo que aquí se forma este
triángulo de aquí sus coordenadas están
dadas por la base y por la altura verdad
y aquí tenemos una ángulo teta entonces
podemos utilizar funciones
trigonométricas para poder determinar
quién es la base que sería la primera
coordenada de esta rotación y para
determinar la altura también usamos
estas corden perdón estas funciones
trigonométricas entonces recordemos
alguna función trigonométricas que
relacione el ángulo con algo que
conocemos de hecho éste tiene longitud 1
verdad porque él
por uno
el vector uno tiene longitud uno y
simplemente estamos rotando entonces no
estamos el vector es uno lo rotamos si
no estamos afectando su distancia
entonces algo que que relacione la base
o el cateto adyacente a este ángulo con
la hipotenusa y ese es el coseno verdad
del coseno del ángulo es el cateto
adyacente sobre la hipotenusa pero en
este caso la hipotenusa pues es 1
entonces simplemente es cateto adyacente
que es nuestra coordenada x 1
entonces el coseno de este ángulo es
nuestra primera coordenada ahora bien el
seno del ángulo va a ser simplemente
esta altura va a ser ésta
a esta altura ok esta altura es lo que
va a ser el seno del ángulo
bueno ya les dije el resultado y eso es
porque el seno del ángulo escate
propuesto sobre hipotenusa verdad que es
el cateto opuesto es hacia donde está
viendo el ángulo y la hipotenusa mide 1
así que simplemente esto será nuestra
segunda coordenada que es la altura de
este vector entonces el seno del ángulo
es la segunda coordenada de esta
rotación déjenme quitar esto que ya no
nos va a servir
solo recuerden muy bien como como están
definidas las las transformaciones las
funciones trigonométricas y ahora nos
vamos con la rotación del ángulo teta
pero de nuestro vector de dos entonces
si nosotros rota nos digamos por aquí
este 2 un ángulo teta
y digamos este
ahí tenemos nuestra rotación la rotación
del ángulo perdón de dos en un ángulo
theta y nuevamente podemos construir un
triángulo rectángulo verdad aquí tenemos
este ángulo y nuevamente quien va a ser
ahora la coordenada y la coordenada en x
pues simplemente va a ser esta distancia
que es exactamente la altura digamos de
este triángulo visto si la base fuera
estuviera sobre el eje de las 'íes'
entonces esta altura nuevamente es el
coseno del ángulo verdad algo que me
relacione con el cateto opuesto con la
hipotenusa perdón ese sería el seno del
ángulo verdad el seno del ángulo seno
del ángulo es cateto puesto sobre
hipotenusa que otra vez la hipotenusa
mide 1 y entonces también hay que
observar que como estamos yéndonos en
dirección negativa entonces si va a ser
el seno pero va a ser negativo entonces
este vector de aquí este de vector de
aquí que tiene dos coordenadas
la primera va a ser seno del ángulo pero
en dirección negativa menos seno del
ángulo y ahora cuál sería la altura de
esta de este vector pues es simplemente
esta altura verdad esta altura que está
definida con el coseno del ángulo verdad
base perdón cateto adyacente /
hipotenusa entonces este de aquí
simplemente es el coseno coseno del
y entonces ya tenemos muy bien
construido quiénes son las columnas de
nuestra matriz de la transformación de
rotación verdad porque dijimos que estas
eran las columnas así que la matriz la
matriz a la matriz a está definida de la
siguiente forma la rotación esta
rotación de eeuu no es la primera
columna josé no de teta seno de teta y
la otra columna será menos seno de teta
coseno de teta jose no muy bien esta es
mi transformación de hecho más bien es
la matriz asociada a la transformación
ya podemos usar cualquier rotación como
una matriz por un vector entonces
estábamos diciendo recordemos que
decíamos que una rotación en un ángulo
teta es una función que va de r2 en r2
vimos que es lineal y por lo tanto se
escribe como una matriz por un vector
entonces la rotación en un ángulo theta
de un vector x es una matriz que de
hecho ya sabemos cuáles es la matriz
que tiene aquí coseno seno - seno
coseno y que multiplica nuestro vector
pues que tiene coordenadas x1 y x2 muy
bien entonces ahora tú dirás oye pues
qué bueno que ya encontramos una matriz
pero de todos modos me está diciendo que
tengo que sacar cosenos y senos y un
ángulo no me está diciendo más entonces
aquí dependerá del ángulo en particular
que nos estemos tomando verdad como le
voy a hacer voy a hacer un ejemplo muy
concreto qué pasaría si queremos
calcular la rotación de 45 grados de un
vector x entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es sustituir estos 45 grados
dentro de cada una de estas funciones
trigonométricas entonces esto será la
matriz una matriz que va a ser que
resulta de evaluar en 45 grados tanto el
coseno y el seno y poner los signos
correspondientes
cuál es el coseno de 45 grados bueno eso
es raíz de 2 sobre 2 verdad ya lo hemos
hecho en otros vídeos lo mismo va a
pasar con el seno el seno de 45 es raíz
de 2 sobre 2
tenemos menos seno de teta entonces
sería menos raíz de 2 sobre 2 y cosenos
de teta nuevamente es raíz de 2 sobre
dos que multiplica a nuestro vector x ok
vamos a ver cómo se vería esta
transformación
si yo tengo aquí mis ejes digamos aquí
están mis ejes esto estamos trabajando
en r2 y no sé digamos que tenemos alguna
figura interesante digamos que tenemos
un cuadrado aquí
un cuadrado que está reposando sobre el
eje de las equis ok y queremos rotar 45
grados entonces vamos a utilizar una
transformación que rote todo esto en un
ángulo de 45 grados entonces lo que se
vería es más o menos de la siguiente
forma déjenme poner otro color
quedando muy amarillo todo tenemos este
estos ejes nuevamente es el mismo
espacio y lo que vamos a hacer es esta
línea rotarla a 45 grados para que
tengamos una mejor referencia ahí está
lo que sería el eje x rotado y por
supuesto ahí se va a encontrar nuestro
cuadrado verdad aquí va a estar nuestro
cuadrado rotado ya 45 grados que
entonces esto es muy bonito y muy útil
por ejemplo si uno quiere utilizar no se
quiere programar un jueguito de pinball
o de pelotas que chocan y demás bueno
esto esto puede resultar muy útil porque
hacerlo a mano puede ser muy complicado
yo cuando hice a mano un programa éste
fue fue bastante complicado pero esta
herramienta utilizando matrices es mucho
más útil y más fácil de resolver cuando
lo intentamos programar y solo para que
quede muy claro qué es lo que pasó estos
vértices del cuadrado que estaban
asociados a cierto vector verdad
entonces este vector al rotar los 45
grados fue el que fue a dar acá
este vector de acá arriba por ejemplo
este de aquí
este vector al rotarlo nos dio este otro
vector y este vector de acá al final
este de esta esquina es el que fue a dar
después de la transformación a este otro
vector de todos modos espero hayas
encontrado esto muy bueno y muy útil
creo que es de las primeras
transformaciones que que me parecen
bonitas y ya puedes pensar en cómo
extenderlo a tres dimensiones si alguna
vez lo intentas
a hacer a mano las rotaciones en 3-d en
tres dimensiones se vuelven muy confusas
pero con el próximo vídeo vamos a hacer
rotaciones en tres dimensiones alrededor
de algunos ejes